queridos
meu nome é semita cevallos eu sou filha
de um equatoriano e de uma cearense
eu sou irmã de um síndrome de down eu
fui criado em uma fé de origem americana
meu nome é judeu eu estudei música
durante seis anos na polônia
eu faço doutorado em música da unirio
eu trabalho com os russos
aqui na cidade de lviv na escola do
teatro bolshoi no brasil e eu pratico
zen budismo o dízimo de origem japonesa
então com vocês podem perceber eu sou
uma pessoa que gosta de transitar entre
diferentes culturas diferentes países
entre pessoas de diferentes profissões e
o grande sonho da minha vida era estudar
na europa eu queria saber porque os
músicos europeus eram tão bons
eu queria receber uma educação formal em
uma universidade européia
mas como filha da classe média baixa
brasileira aquele sonho parecia um pouco
distante mas não impossível
eu realizei o bacharelado em piano na
escola de música e belas artes do paraná
e logo após eu comecei a trabalhar na
secretaria de cultura em são josé dos
pinhais
eu fiquei sabendo que a prefeitura havia
firmado um acordo bilateral com a cidade
polonesa chamada pós na voz nem a quinta
cidade em número de habitantes da
polônia uma das grandes cidades
eu vi ali a oportunidade de realizar meu
sonho eu entrei então em contato com os
responsáveis por esse acordo e depois de
um ano e embarcava rumo à terra de
frederic chopin
chegando lá primeiro choque cultural eu
não sabia nem falar nem ler nem entender
a língua polonesa eu não sei
é falar o nome do lugar onde eu estudava
nem o nome do meu professor
eu estudava na academia nos 20km ona
ignatz e goiana padres que o gol fosse
nário e o nome do meu professor era
bogumil novitskiy então de manhã eu ia
às classes de ícones para estrangeiros e
à tarde eu estudava piano e ali eu
começava então a entender por que os
europeus eram tão bons músicos
eu fui submetida a um intenso e rio do
programa de estudos técnico pianístico
eu estudava em média de seis a oito
horas por dia e na classe do professor
no vídeo que nós tínhamos dois pianos de
cauda ele sentava em nenhum eu em outro
e nós fazemos exercícios ali toda semana
durante um ano
no segundo e no terceiro ano nós
escolhemos então obras do repertório
pianístico começamos a estudar
professores que ensinam a gente estudava
no final deste terceiro ano eu estava no
auge da minha forma musical
foi então que decidi parar de tocar como
artistas nós queremos ser admirados nós
almejamos pela harmonia dos sons
nós queremos que a nossa performance
seja perfeita mas quase sempre se tem um
fundo hedonista egóica eu não via mais
sentido em fazer a arte pela arte
dessa forma eu senti um vazio de
significado naquilo que eu estava
fazendo
eu fiquei sem tocar piano durante sete
anos eu ainda continuei na polônia
estudei em musicologia que engloba parte
de teoria história e filosofia da música
voltei ao brasil
trabalhei novamente na secretaria de
cultura em são josé dos pinhais
agora como diretora do departamento de
música e foi então que eu sentir
novamente a vontade de tocar sentir uma
saudade
e aí surgiu a oportunidade de ser
pianista na escola do teatro bolshoi no
brasil e depois de sete anos sem tocar
piano eu iria novamente fazer uma prova
e eu passei hoje eu sou o pianista na
escola do teatro bolshoi no brasil além
de ter iniciado as aulas de balé
eu sou professora de educação musical e
professora de piano e ali eu tenho
desenvolvido uma forma de trabalhar a
arte para desenvolver as potencialidades
dos meus alunos cada aluno é único
precisa de alguma coisa diferente e
alguns precisam de disciplina
outros precisam ganhar confiança outros
precisam de amor através da música nós
vamos trabalhando tudo isso o que me
surpreende é que dessa forma mais livre
mais humana os meus alunos têm alcançado
altos níveis de excelência musical mas
eu queria mais
eu queria levar a música para lugares
aonde ela não iria normalmente
assistindo a um documentário sobre uma
penitenciária no alabama nos estados
unidos e vendo o sério trabalho
realizado ali eu pensando se eu não a
minha música não poderia beneficiar os
detentos
aqui na cidade de joinville eu entrei
então em contato com o juiz da vara de
execuções penais solicitando uma visita
à penitenciária e o meu pedido foi
aceito
depois de certo tempo então as portas da
penitenciária industrial de joinville se
abriram para essa pianista e musicólogo
naquele momento eu não poderia imaginar
as surpresas e as transformações que
aquele lugar
daria para minha vida eu fui recebida
com um sorriso pela gerente da unidade e
começou a me falar sobre todo o trabalho
realizado ali um momento muito
importante ela tinha um orgulho na fala
dela por por ser este um complexo
prisional considerado modelo
aqui no brasil pelo sistema brasileiro o
índice de reincidência é de somente 80%
aqui na penitenciária industrial é de
23%
e essa conversa foi na parte
administrativa da penitenciária
foi então que ela me convidou para
entrar nas dependências do prédio
eu confesso que eu tive medo mas a minha
curiosidade era ainda maior
eu entrei eu vi o ambulatório eo pátio
de visitas
eu vi os canteiros de trabalho eu vi que
entrei numa cela e eu também vi a escola
e na escola tinha uma biblioteca e na
biblioteca eu perguntei para o detento
responsável
tenho um livro de música aqui e ele
disse não mas para minha surpresa ele
disse eu toco violino
eu continuei a visita e lá atrás eu
comecei a ouvir uma música a música do
violino do jovane havia uma verdade na
música daquele dt uma verdade instituída
de ego
destituída de ambição era uma verdade
pura e eu que já havia estado na
filarmônica de berlim da filarmônica de
los angeles na filarmônica de varsóvia
na sala são paulo eu que já havia visto
grandes intérpretes da música erudita
eu me emocionei ali atrás das grades da
cela da penitenciária
eu achava que iria levar a música para a
penitenciária
mas eu saía dali com aquele presente
depois daquela primeira visita tinha
certeza eu sabia que eu ia voltar ali
muitas e muitas vezes hoje
eu sou a professora de música de
giovanni
eu tive o prazer de ser convidada para
tocar no casamento que ocorreu na
unidade
aqui nós vemos e giovani então tocando e
eu tive o prazer ea honra também de
conhecer os músicos da banda acordes
para liberdade formada pelos detentos
músicos que compartilham o gosto pela
arte feridos
o estado eo sistema não conseguem fazer
tudo sozinho mas nós podemos dar as mãos
em prol de uma sociedade mais justa e
mais igualitária e mais feliz quando eu
comecei a esquecer de mim abandonar as
coisas que eu julgava ser importante pra
mim e comecei a pensar no benefício dos
outros dos meus alunos dos meus alunos
detentos da comunidade da sociedade foi
que coisas como essas começaram a
acontecer pra mim eu sou muito grata por
todas essas oportunidades
eu espero sinceramente e continuar sendo
esse som profundo que toca e que
transforma a vida das pessoas
muito muito obrigado
perdão que não é eu queria agradecer o
juiz de direito da vara de execuções
penais de joinville
o doutor joão marcos boca
quero agradecer ao diretor da
penitenciária richard harrison chagas
dos santos ea gerente de saúde ensino e
promoção social jaqueline facchini por
confiarem no meu trabalho e por permitir
que eu vá todas essas experiências toda
vez que eu passo pela porta na unidade
mas eu quero agradecer mesmo essas três
pessoas por terem permitido que o
giovanni viesse aqui hoje senhoras e
senhores vamos receber o violinista
geovane weeks
nos documentos a onde o juízo deu
permissão para que o giovanni estivesse
que hoje ele escreveu o homem jamais é
uma ameaça sempre uma promessa e com
essas palavras em mente é que eu convido
a todos vocês para ouvirem obra que nós
preparamos para hoje do compositor
brasileiro heitor villa-lobos bachianas
brasileiras número 5 a primeira parte
na interpretação do violinista geovane
weeks e da pianista semitas e vá
essa história não termina por aqui eu
vou continuar indo à penitenciária
industrial de joinville estamos
trabalhando na implantação de um projeto
de música eo jogo vai continuar
estudando violino
torçam por todos esses projetos música e
transformação música e cultura de paz